في ملابسات غامضه يستهدف انفجار منطقه
مكتظه خاضعه لنقاط التفتيش المكثفه في
كابول عاصمه بالقرب من مطار كابول البوابه
الرئيسيه لمن يريد مغادره افغانستان
العامه من الممكن ان تقع في مدن متقدمه
والتي تخضع لاجراءات امنيه مشدده كامريرك
وجارتنا باكستان واوزباكستان وغيرها من
الدول المواطن الافغاني العلي مغلوب على
امره يامل بعد كل تحول سياسي في البلاد ان
يتحسن الوضع الامني لكن اماله غالبا ما
تتلاشى مع كل هجوم جديد
سوف تستمر نعمل قريبا
ترجح المعلومات الاوليه وحيثيات الانفجار
بمسؤوليه الداعش عن العمليه خصوصا ان
السلسله التفجيرات الاخيره تبناها التنظيم
الانفجار هذا استهدف منطقه حساسه وفي اول
يوم من العام الجديد لوجهها رساله واضحه
لسلطات في كابول بان العام الجديد سوف
يكون محذوفا بمثل هذه العمليات عبد الله
نادر العربيه كابول